[Applaudissements]
amoureux il était maladroit et servile
il aurait un à un baisé tous ses cheveux
il avait disons-le presque l'air
imbécile quand il voulait ne pas en être
un à ses yeux mais depuis qu'il l'a eu
depuis qu'il la possède maintenant qu'il
l'a mise dans le fond de son lit n plus
que pour sa
fête qu'il est encore
gentil tel qu'en lui-même enfin le
triomphe le change ce garçon si gentil
si joli si poli un démon sommeillé sous
son visage d'ange et la gloire qui dit
tout le révèle au grand
jour ce n'est pas par hasard qu'il a
pris la soutane à 20 ans il était un
abbé merveilleux connaissant les angile
sur le bout de son âme et il aimait les
hommes autant que le bon Dieu devant
tant de vertu il est monté en grade aux
fêtes liturgiqu aujourd'hui on le voit
en habit de
parade faire le signe de
croix tel qu'en lui-même enfin le
triomphe le change ce garçon si gentil
si joli si poli un démon sommeillé sous
son visage d'ange et la gloire qui dit
tout le révè au Grandon
jour tourneur à 14 ans à 30 ans contre
maître dans l'usine c'était de très loin
le meilleur et pour le comité
d'entreprise peut-être le plus persuasif
de tous ces orateurs mais depuis que
l'État l'a nommé pour qu'il vienne
servir de trait d'union entre bas des
sommet on murmure à la
chaîne qui aurait bien a
changé tel qu'on lui-même enfin le
triomphe le change ce garçon si gentil
si jolie si poli un est mon sommeillé
sous son visage d'ange et la gloire qui
dit tou le révèle au grand
jour débutant il prayit avec les
journalistes le moindre écillon devenait
son copain pour chanter trois chansons
sur la plus humble piste il faisait
comme on dit des pieds et des mains
maintenant qu'en photo il a partout son
buste maintenant qu'il est là où il
voulait monter maintenant c'est tout
justee s'il a encore
chéel qu'on enfin le triomphe ne change
ce garçon si gentil si joli si poli un
démon somillé sous son visage d'ange et
la gloire qui dit
tout le rével
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]